It is easy to forget that even
the simplest movements involve
complex cognitive and
physical processes.
The human body alone consists
of more than 200 joints
and more than 600 muscles.
And it is this incredibly
intricate machine
that allows us to move.
It is the ability to move
that has even given humans
the remarkable flexibility
to do everything
from landing spaceships on the
moon to moon walking on Earth.
Project Tango is a
platform for mobile devices
that can interpret
human movement
in interesting, new ways.
My name is Nikolai.
And in this video,
I will show you
the basics of designing apps and
games with motion tracking that
feels natural to users.
When designing for
motion, you have
to consider how a
user moves naturally,
which physical setting
they will be in,
and why they need to move.
You may have seen how
mobile devices can
track movement in games and apps
by using rotational tracking.
You may have used
it to look around
Google Street View
on racing games
to control the steering wheel.
However, if you only
track the device rotation,
you have to come up with
other ways to move in the app.
You can do so by
tapping on the screen
or by using virtual
D-Pads to go places.
If the user is looking
at a virtual moon colony,
like here, they can use the
device rotation to look around.
But they need
another input method,
like virtual D-Pads
to move around.
The lack of fine-grain tracking
in current mobile devices
limits what we can do with them.
And Project Tango device
solves these problems
by adding a camera system
that, like us humans,
uses visual recognition
to keep track of itself.
This allows the user to
not only rotate, but also
move the device in any
direction they choose
and see it reflected
in their app.
You can implement
this on a small scale.
The users can use
this input method
to view the moon colony
while sitting at a table.
This works great if the
virtual world is small.
In this example, we have
constrained the users
so they don't get
up and walk away.
But what if the user did
get up and walked away?
Project Tango can track
a large scale too.
This means the user does
not need to stay seated
but can move around
freely and naturally.
In that case, the user will
have a much larger play space
and could explore
more of the colony
or the craters of the moon.
In the virtual
worlds we create, you
can do things you
can't do in real life.
You can run really, really fast
and move very, very slowly.
This is how it looks if
we move at normal speed.
So if you're tracking
the user's movement
through the physical
world, a safe bet
is to map the physical motion
proportionally to the virtual.
If we once again
walk at normal speed,
but slow down the
user's virtual movement,
it can look like this.
Notice how we have to
walk really far before we
get past that building block?
Not only is this
not very exciting,
it can create a feeling
that the entire system is
unable to keep up or that
everything in the world
is unnaturally big.
On the other hand,
it would be great
if we could move at supersonic
speed in the virtual world
instead, right?
Not so fast.
If we speed up
motion so you only
have to walk a
little to get far,
things can start
to feel jittery.
In other words, things are
easiest to comprehend and use
if they behave naturally
like we're used to.
At times, there
may be good reasons
to letting the user move faster
or slower than they really are.
For example, if they
are attempting to sight
see the entire moon on foot or
probing very tiny moon rocks.
In these cases, we have
found that providing a way
to manually adjust the speed
makes it less confusing,
such as a Speed Boost button to
skip the boring bits on the way
to the moon crater.
When you integrate
motion tracking
in the user experience, think
about what kind you need.
Are you creating
a small world that
fits on a table or will it
require the whole building
to fit?
You will need to decide
on rotation, small scale,
large scale, a combination for
the tracking, and how to make
it feel natural.
Users always have expectations,
even when bouncing around
their virtual space colony.
Visit our Google+ community
and join us in our journey.
We are excited to see what you
will build with Project Tango.
[MUSIC PLAYING]